what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we are back with the boys dear becky and
with season three basically done uh
hopefully this will satisfy your need
for boys related content
but what this does is this initially
picks up with billy butcher and becky
and what we end up getting is of course
them kind of in a pool hall now one of
the things to know is that when it came
to becky and billy butcher one it was
it's kind of easy to look at the life of
billy butcher at this point in time and
believe that his life is perfect but the
reality here is becky's gonna hit on
some stuff that he's still dealing with
and it's actually things that won't
really come to bear until we basically
end up getting into the main boys series
itself but of course the two of them are
basically in a pool hall kind of
enjoying a bit of woody banter between
the two of them and of course she's
busting his balls because he makes this
joke where he talks about how it's girls
against the guys in pool and women's
suck it pool and so becky pours uh water
on his crotch and it makes it look like
he pissed his pants and then she's like
so what are you gonna do you're gonna
sit here and you're gonna mope around
about the fact that you look like you
pissed your pants and be embarrassed or
you're going to do something and billy
butcher ever the man's man gets up just
pants for the world to see and just
starts playing some pool
[Laughter]
which is exactly how you're supposed to
act in this situation and so again you
know this kind of funny funny banter
that goes back and forth one thing to
understand there's a lot of love between
the two of them here right there is a
lot of love and a lot of connection
between the two of them and so of course
you know once this banter is over with
and the game kind of gets finished billy
butcher takes you back home and does the
deed but the following morning when they
wake up and this is really the important
thing here because remember when you
have billy butcher in bed by himself
here that's him in the the present at
the stories being as the story is being
told where he's just kind of thinking
back on all these memories that he has
with becky but one of the things that
happens is that in the aftermath right
the next morning when it's him and becky
uh of course you know she's taking a
bath and just kind of reading the paper
and that sort of stuff one of the things
she talks about is the internal struggle
people deal with and when it comes to a
lot of the younger kids that she works
with and things like that what she
points out here is that the things
they've been through the things they've
seen right abuse and violence and all
that kind of stuff it never goes away
but it never stops being a part of them
that the reality is there are times
especially when you're younger the world
is going to show you a part of itself
that you were just never meant to see at
that age and the reality is it's going
to change you it's going to become an
irrevocable part of you it can't be
fixed it can't be eliminated the best
you can do is learn to live with it and
try to live the the best life you
possibly can it's why they always say
that bad parents are the ones that screw
their kids up for the rest of their
lives because that's usually what
happens right like a parent makes some
ridiculous decision or silly decision in
the moment they pawn it off on the idea
well you know there's no handbook on how
to be a parent and they basically screw
up their kids for the rest of their
lives so as a result of that billy
butcher kind of hears this and really
recollects on his own experiences both
fighting in the war right fighting in
the falklands i think is what it was as
well as just his experiences in fighting
like gangs and things like that and what
he's learned is that over the course of
his life because of his childhood these
traumas he's experienced have come to
the surface from time to time the the
war effort that he was in was almost the
best time for it to be there and it's
one of those things where you would kind
of look at that and say okay so he's got
like a finite amount of just personal
struggle in him and when he's in a
conflict like war he can kind of
regurgitate it all out but the reality
is that it's endless right it is an
infinite thing so there's no conflict
out there that would be of such a degree
that would allow him to finally get it
all out that's never going to happen
right it just keeps coming and coming
and so it's one of those things where he
kind of hears what she says and it
becomes important later on down the line
but in a lot of ways becky's very
important to him because becky is what
anchors him to reality and keeps him
from going too far off the deep end but
of course with becky out of the picture
having died it's no wonder how it is
that billy butcher ended up becoming so
sadistic and so violent and really just
a straight-up sociopath or psychopath
when it came to the boys series and so
what you end up doing is switching over
to uh to julian baxter puke now again
one of the things to remember when it
comes to dear becky is this doesn't
necessarily focus on vaught american as
a whole although it kind of does that
what you have is you have basically the
superhero division right superhero
development for vaude american those are
the ones that basically find individuals
out there who have superpowers that are
marketable because it's one thing to
have abilities it's another to be a
person with marketable abilities because
vaude american is all about making money
and so superhero development are the
ones they find those heroes that are
marketable they bring them in they give
them a story a new identity an origin
all that kind of stuff and they send
them out there on some kind of a team
and depending on how they resonate with
the general public that they could
increase in popularity and as that goes
on they could possibly become part of
the seven or something like that what
julian baxter puke did is he was brought
in by vlad american for reasons that
weren't explicitly made clear outside of
the fact that maybe some strings were
pulled but he was part of media corps
and that what he's doing is basically he
has his own kind of plan that we'll talk
about here in a minute but basically
he's creating rifts in vaude american
and so there's a bit of turmoil going on
inside vaught itself and so what happens
is there's this kind of debate that
happens on national tv where basically
it's julian baxter puke against another
guy and they're talking about the nature
of these superheroes right the the team
the scorchers that's out there and they
all kind of have offensive names and
it's really interesting the way that
julian plays this because what he does
here is instead of like defending the
names as just being like well i mean
they're only offensive because you see
it that way instead what he does is the
guy who's claiming these names are
offensive he paints that guy out to be a
villain what happens here and what he
says is you're dismissing this as as you
know as like homophobia and racism is
like a bit of fun right that's the the
question that's being asked of julian
puke right and and even the guy who's
arguing with him says because that's the
same excuse that you've used to defend
the kind of journalism that you've
peddled back in the uk the same chirpy
cheery and frankly quite nauseating
stuff and so when the the the mediator
kind of asks like you know that's a good
point you know what's your counter
argument to this point this is when
julian baxter puke pulls this just
amazing moment and makes this guy out to
be the villain and what he says is well
that was certainly mr tatchell's line
when we cross swords uh on the bbc and
i'll say the same thing now that i said
to him then calm down no one's trying to
offend anyone but there is a point i
would like to raise here and that's that
these heroes all chose their own names
which of course we know isn't true but
he says they all chose their own names
when taschler starts to to interrupt him
he says well let me finish first right
he says uh the moment a superhero takes
his name comes at a crucial point in
their origin process he'll have
undergone a good deal of trial and
frustration as his powers develop
possibly even trauma as well it's
regarded as well as quite a sacred
moment by many in the superhuman
community and so the the question of the
moderator is so you're saying that we
need to be more respectful and his
response is yes i am if anything else i
think it's a great opportunity for us to
begin a conversation about boundaries
and so what julian baxter pugh has done
here is instead of being on the defense
and saying well no no you know it's it's
look it only it's not it's not that
racist look it's not that bad instead of
doing that it's no no here's the issue
what you're doing is you're saying these
people who are taking this name and
making it their identity you're saying
it's wrong and you're saying they're
wrong what you're doing is you're saying
the world can believe whatever it wants
to believe as long as i agree with it
that's a huge amount of arrogance and
narcissism you are not that important
and you never were i'm sorry if you
tricked yourself into believing that but
that's not the case you are as
irrelevant as anybody else out there so
how dare you come to somebody out there
and say you are wrong for choosing that
name for yourself and tying that name to
your identity and the entire basis
behind this is because i find it
offensive you know like it's a really
really great argument and it paints them
out to be the bad guys like i said it's
a great way to win those kinds of
arguments don't go on the defense make
them go on the defense go on the offense
right just become rabid make them look
like the villains here make them justify
how their case is anything other than
being narcissistic and then in turn
watch them completely fold in on
themselves and collapse under the weight
of their own arrogance it's a great
stance to take and so the funny thing
here is that the boys in them are kind
of like so you're so like you know with
with them knowing julian baxter puke
seeing what he's about and knowing what
vaude american is they're like okay this
is kind of ridiculous right like none of
this like all this is nonsensical but
notice here baxter puke is not trying to
win over uh billy butcher and those guys
he's trying to win over the general
public and he's doing it he's
successfully doing so and so it's a
really interesting thing because having
this conversation say we need to talk
about boundaries and all that kind of
stuff billy butcher and then see right
through it but they're also smarter than
the average bear and they're holding all
the cards they know everything about
about america they know how crooked they
are they know how corrupt they are the
general probably doesn't the average
person would like to believe they're
holding all the cards but they're not
they never really know exactly
everything that's going on even with
regards to their own arguments they just
think they do and so it's cool because
it kind of pisses off billy butcher for
a second but in the end the whole idea
and really the basis behind why they're
concerned about puke is because you have
mother's milk who steps up and says okay
so like the soups that he has there they
don't really matter right they're not
really capable of doing anything they're
not on the same level as the seven or
anything like that and so when it comes
to pew himself they're like this guy's
got no real experience with media until
he moved out west in 1993 before
everything started going on you know
they say that when it comes to pug that
he was never really a guy on this level
didn't really have any experience with
media until he came out and started
working for vod american right that he's
heading up the acquisitions office of
vaught american petroleum and then
starts working his way up the ranks
which as anybody in any real job site
will tell you it's not about what you
know it's about who you know and that's
how you find yourself getting promotions
working up and different things like
that is it fair no but just learn to
deal with it and play the game as it's
being played right either that or you
can just sit around and be pissed off
about it never go anywhere and so it's
one of those things where they're kind
of asking the question okay so at the
end of the day if he's running media
core and he has the scorchers what's the
motivation behind this right is he is he
kind of vying to basically take over a
superhero development at vaught american
what's his angle here right what's his
end game and so that's when mallory
steps up and says okay there's a little
more to this guys than you than you
initially think now remember mallory is
an ex-cia guy right he's a former spy
spook whatever you want to call him
right he's a guy that operates behind
the scenes and so he has a lot of
information on things that have gone on
out there when it comes to bought
american even though the legend really
knows a lot more a lot more than mallory
does when it comes to the nature of
vaughn itself what he says here is that
there was a tribe that was wiped out and
another tribe moved in right out there i
think i think they said it was out in
africa somewhere and so what what
mallory says kind of picking up after
really picking up with mother's milk is
that where the actions of julian baxter
pugh with regards to bought american
petroleum dealt with something called
the grand savannah dam that what had
happened is that there was a tribe that
had died out there now the way this
worked and what it is that mallory tells
us here is that there was a tribe that
died and then another tribe moved in and
he says no one told that local tribe
that the soil had to basically be farmed
with techniques that they weren't used
to and the people who could have told
them that were all basically gone and so
he said that's one of the finer points
of ethnic cleansing essentially and so
what he says is that it was noted that
at the time the new tribe were much more
receptive to offers from vaude american
petroleum who wanted their part of the
territory for drilling but nothing could
be proven about the failure of the dam
what screwed vaught was the demise of
that second tribe by famine which no one
had foreseen a humanitarian catastrophe
that rendered the project beyond toxic
in public relations terms and so what
this basically meant is that you had
julian who wanted to basically set up a
kind of drilling uh operation out by the
the grants were out of the grand
savannah dam but because of the fact
that the first tribe was killed the
second tribe moved in didn't know how to
how to till the land they died it turned
into a great big huge humanitarian thing
if if what vaude had done in the
aftermath of that was gone in there and
started drilling it would have pissed
off the world everybody would have hated
bought america for it i mean they would
have hated them for a little while and
then like a few weeks later everybody
would have forgotten about it i mean
that's how things work now but uh that's
what would have happened right everybody
would have just been exceedingly mad
right from a public relations
perspective it would have been a
nightmare so while vlog would have
certainly been able to weather the storm
why give yourself a headache if you
don't have to and so that's when
mother's milk starts connecting the dots
based on the assignment that was given
to him by mallory and where what what he
basically does is he introduces
stormfront right now stormfront in the
comics and the boys comics totally
different from stormf well not really
even totally different but different in
a lot of ways from stormfront from the
uh from the tv show but what we're
basically told here at least what
mother's milk says is that there was a
vaude american internal memo that the
legend had sent over to mother's milk
and that this was from victory comics
when they did a charity book for the
grand savannah damn vaude said they
could use any characters they wanted but
they couldn't use stormfront no public
appearances no using his image in the
book he could not go anywhere near this
at all and so that's when frenchie asked
the question does stormfront have the
power or did he have the power to
destroy that savannah dam in the first
place and basically run out that
original tribe and that's when mallory
says yes in his little finger he could
have easily done that and so that's what
mother smells like i never would have
connected this but it makes perfect
sense that what happened here is that
julian baxter pube wants to use
superheroes for things that no one had
ever and should ever use them for that
he tried once and he screwed up that in
effect what julian baxter pugh seemed to
have done was use stormfront to destroy
the dam and take out the first tribe but
before vaude american could get in there
and start drilling the second tribe went
in there and then the second tribe died
and that created the whole great big
huge humanitarian pr nightmare that
basically julian baxter pugh was trying
to try to you know generate income for
vaughn and screwed it up and so that's
when billy butcher's like okay we need
to find out information about stormfront
and so what he ends up doing is of
course going to see vicker now of course
you guys remember vicar from the last
video that we did the two of them kind
of start talking and it's sort of funny
is because as the two of them are having
this discussion one of the things that
happens is that the way the marketing is
done for uh for vicar himself they're
all referred to like him and the people
like him are referred to as the children
of stormfront that is kind of the
marketing thing that's set up now of
course you could immediately look at
vicar and no that's not the case the guy
doesn't look anything like stormfront
and there's obviously no relation there
but for the general public they
absolutely ate it up because that was
the nature of the of the the story that
was being marketed but kind of a funny
thing happened is that as they're
talking you know vicar basically says
speaking of the children of stormfront
and he basically calls in the other kids
that are there right all these kind of
thor archetypes essentially and so the
idea here of vicar is to quite literally
set up an ambush to take out billy
butcher now here's one of the things to
keep in mind if you're familiar with the
boys as it exists right now your
immediate response is no way these guys
stand a chance billy butcher's way too
powerful but one thing to remember here
billy butcher does not have compound v
he's just a regular guy with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace
you